hi everybody it's me Noel and I'm here
and I'm gonna show you a little bit
about the Vulcan tech gospel 3 app which
is currently in its beta testing right
now so you can see right here this is
our logo which is a skull which is one
of my deceased cats that I lived with
for 13 years and I figured since all the
other Vulcan tech gospel logos or many
of them have skulls I would keep that
going with this so here I go clicking on
it boom you get a little splash screen
turn the audio on real quick and so this
song that you're hearing was made by
Russ and I'm really thankful for him
he's an OG in the flow world and what
I'm gonna show you right now is a very
quick tour of how to understand this and
this will be related to some of the
accompanying documents that have been
produced for the Vulcan Tech Gospel 3 so
what I'm gonna do first is you can see
that it's a grid of 36 total squares a
6x6 grid and in the upper right hand
corner these four patterns right here
these actually have two patterns for
each square and if you click on that you
can xec I can alternate between the
anti-spin versions of that pattern okay
so so also here we have a variety of
crops that you can select toys that fan
coupe clubs triads and okay
sorry bro start until you have the
double rope dart which could happen yeah
and so also I'll just go ahead and show
you how one square works and then
hopefully that'll be a good thing to get
you all started and get you excited for
the app that Michael has been building
and I'm really really excited about this
so here we go so let's go ahead and
click a tricky pattern let's go to this
pattern which is taug same versus split
up so that's the timing direction of the
hands and the crops and right here this
is the pattern that will get perused
okay so go ahead go ahead and click on
that and boom so you can notice that the
hands are moving around in together time
same direction
cursor and the props are meeting our
doing split opposite you notice their
opposite on the Y fold facing it on the
edge option the live while placing it
and you can see those snapshots on the
side here people facing in tog in tog
split tog split means your hands are
together but your props are split on
this menu page there's a bunch of some
things we can change the crop place
you're curious about so you try and do
this there's actually in the option menu
a way for you to do alternate alternate
versions of the triad like orientations
when they make you see some fan action
here it's pretty sweet and kind of some
little double stabs here it seems to be
the trend anyway and boom it's fantastic
the pattern you're doing is actually
bite right here in the bottom left the
hand time direction is listed right here
in here and also along the top with its
relative timing some of these other
buttons do stuff too so if I click this
this little clock here will pause or
slow down the animation and one more
thing before we go on this first little
jaunt into the VP gif if I click the
eyeball right here what happens is it
actually unlocks this and now you can
pinch zoom let's say you were curious
about seeing this little closer you can
get in there and check it out zoom it
okay and we have lots of options for
example of this trail you find kind of
annoying just real quick I'll just show
you here's the option menu and let's get
rid of some crop trails and many of
those achievements you need to unlock
the ax playing the game which we'll go
over a little bit more later okay and so
there you go there's a little intro to
the app and really excited and here it
is and super stoked hope you have a
wonderful day and you continue to follow
a Facebook page or maybe join the small
group
and thanks much